the nominees for best picture of the
year are Forrest Gump Wendy Wendy fine
ermine Steve Tisch Steve stocking my
eyes producers Four Weddings and a
funeral duncan Kenworthy producer pulp
fiction Lawrence bender producer quiz
show Robert Redford Michael Jacobs Julie
and craning Michael Nozick produces the
Shawshank Redemption
Mickey Marvin producer
and the Oscar goes to Forrest Gump
Wendy phenomena from Steve fish a stocky
producing
I'd like to say thank you to the Academy
for this honor and it's a just so
wonderful to be acknowledged with a
great group of movies nine years ago I
met a very special man who has since
taken me on an amazing journey there
were many people who gave him gifts
along the way Eric Roth
you gave far as to soul Tom Hanks
you gave forest a heart and Bob Zemeckis
you gave forest a vision
tsch let's do Starkey you're great
co-parents forest was a labor of love to
many people our wonderful cast and crew
sherry John Michell John Barrie Arthur
all the people paramount
Winston Craig Rand to my parents
grandparents family thank you for your
support to my husband Mark Canton for
your love and always saying go make this
dream a reality my parents always said
dreams can come true and to my own
children Dorothea Henry and James if you
doubt it
please remember tonight because I always
will thank
all over the political map people have
been calling forests their own but far
as Gump isn't about politics or
conservative values it's about humanity
it's about respect tolerance and
unconditional love
and tonight we should all feel proud
that we are in a business where we
entertain we educate and we empower I'd
like to thank my family my parents Joan
and Bob love to Jamie and to my two
wonderful children Hilary and Willie and
to my four best friends and finally
thanks to all the Forrest Gump's in the
world
well I truly want to thank the Academy
for making me be the final person to
thank them tonight now I don't know if
it was destiny or if it was chance that
brought together the talented cast an
extraordinary crew of Forrest Gump but
maybe as Forrest said maybe it was both
maybe both were happening at the same
time but in any case as I look back I
can't imagine making this film without
any one of them or without the
commitment of Sherry Lansing and
Paramount Studios but most of all the
picture could not have been made without
the gentle spirit of Tom Hanks and the
guidance and inspiration of the guy we
fondly call Bob Z the truly visionary
director Bob Zemeckis
and I wish to thank them all and
especially my wife Olivia who has stood
beside me over the years and everything
I've done and hello to my parents thank
you all very much
you